este helicóptero de la fuerza aérea
ucraniana sobrevuela posiciones rusas en
un lugar no especificado de la región de
daniasca
es una de las imágenes más recientes de
la contraofensiva ucraniana cuyo inicio
ya reconoció el presidente bolodimir
selensky el comandante del helicóptero
conocido como Denisse habla sobre esta
misión de combate
Nuestro objetivo es alcanzar objetivos
enemigos en tierra sus soldados su
equipo sus posiciones fortificadas
nuestros cohetes pueden expulsarlos de
sus fortificaciones la contraofensiva
que tuvo varios retrasos por temas
logísticos Avanza en el sureste de
Ucrania
kiev asegura que sus tropas recuperaron
una cuarta aldea en danniasc esto lo
lleve
blacknet scusne y macarifas son las
otras tres localidades que el ejército
ucraniano dice haber recapturados menos
de 24 horas
los soldados izaron la bandera ucraniana
en esto lo lleve al principio el enemigo
resistió trató de repeler nuestro ataque
con artillería logramos tomar la
iniciativa y poco a poco casa por casa
fuimos recuperando el pueblo
Aproximadamente matamos a 10 soldados
enemigos y tomamos cuatro prisioneros el
Instituto para el estudio de la guerra
reconocido Team estadounidense verificó
satelitalmente avances ucranianos en el
oeste de nest y también en saporilla
Rusia reconoce el avance de Ucrania pero
minimiza su éxito
Moscú monitorea de cerca la
contraofensiva y asegura que kiev ya
está utilizando equipos occidentales en
terreno como los tanques leopardos